hey guys Murray valeri on the road
stories podcast how's it going how you
doing are you living are you living so
what you're doing got a great show for
you guys this week very excited about it
going to tell you up front right now
it's a bit of a roller coaster so strap
in um doesn't go completely off the
rails it doesn't go full crazy train but
uh it's it's it's it's fun it's fine
just take some tram I mean because it's
a bit of a wild ride before we get
started I want to talk to you about one
thing and that one thing is audible com
what why are you talking to me about
audible com I'll tell you what I'm
talking to you about audible com two
things a they sponsored the Los Angeles
podcast festival this year which was
awesome it made it the best year to date
on my opinion and to they are giving
wrote stories podcast listeners a
special deal now for those of you don't
know about audible com audible.com is
content includes more than 180,000 audio
programs from leading audio book
publishers broadcasters entertainers
magazine and newspaper publishers and
business information providers that's a
lot of content and it also comes with
free apps for iPhone iPad androids and
windows phones you can download and
listen on iOS devices androids kindle
fires windows phones and over something
like 500 mp3 players that's insane but
unlike other streaming and rental
services with audible you own your books
that's right you own your books that is
a commitment and like the greatest
commitment of all marriage there's a way
out let's say you don't like your book
let's say you get halfway through
Catcher in the Rye and you're like this
blows you can return it and they'll
replace it with another title completely
for free no questions asked don't like
catcher in the rye your sketcher in the
corn I don't know whatever book you
choose you can return it they'll give
you a new title for free no questions
asked anytime any day of the week I'm
going on the road this weekend so I've
been looking for which book i'm going to
read because i've been shopping around
for a new book lately and I'm big David
Sedaris fan so there's a bunch of David
Sedaris books on there the Keith
Richards book man the keys
can you believe I never right you guys
know how much of a music fan I am and I
never read the Keith Richards book but I
think I'm gonna go with they're gonna go
with Elvis Costello unfaithful music and
disappearing ink so I think that's what
I do on the road I'm gonna take all this
Costello unfaithful music and
disappearing ink and check that out now
uh give you guys a report on it what
book are you guys gonna choose oh I
forgot to tell you you get a book if
you're a road stories listeners are you
go to audible.com forward slash road you
get a 30-day trial and a free book of
your choice a free book of your choice
which remember you own so over 180,000
things to choose from if I've said this
once on this podcast I said it a
thousand times as a nation we don't read
nearly enough so go to audible.com
forward slash road get your 30-day free
trial get your free book pick a good one
shoot me an email let me know what you
got I'll let you know about this Elvis
Costello book and and we'll have our own
little book club the road stories book
club who's bringing the brie life on the
road it's a taco tangra course
representing guns and these fights
ketchup like running with the runs dome
blacklist bounced checks great a
bachelorette don'ts in the front making
out for your set and the delights doing
home or missing merge turn try the
rental car has another mega church turn
juice keys vagina 50 cell phone is gone
one big ball and
Oh
God first it's like the green really
good you're in a green room somewhere I
believe you that when you go in the
green room and there especially being
relative all the thousand fiji water
don't first of all yeah your backpack
and i will recede there's no fiji water
it's just water from the fountain you
know we don't get by the water when I
get it save gotta sell tickets get
bottled water hey and your price gets
the most new material I've heard from
area six months I know fairy spit water
on myself that was funny thanks for
tuning the road stories podcast
everybody not giving Gary cannon a
chance to rebuttal uh everybody know
we're doing today yeah I just ambushed
the mornin and Gary on it on their show
but yeah yeah we're here yeah do this
well ready you surprised how many people
show up me like so this is podcast oh
really would we see what do we know
we're ready yeah well and then they
start doing it oh that really ya know oh
yeah the comic who doesn't hahaha we're
talking about my more Gary would do that
but he has no bits we were talking about
movies before and I was watching Vision
Quest was on a couple nights ago on
Showtime Matthew Modine nezam eveleen
yeah yeah ice skating this area
restlessly a wrestling right yeah yeah
the rest of the dude that had the
telephone pole on his shoulders he was
also bleachers hey what's his name shoot
yeah cube and he had his Indian friend
that gave him the Vision Quest oh that's
right to defeat the that's right champ
but he was banging like that uh the old
chick from medic she was like yeah like
25 back then she was hot but he's in
high school it's really funny she comes
into the school and they're all like oh
my god like they've never seen a girl
before but she could be she could she
could have gotten like if that movie
happened today she arrested for
statutory rape I looked at that oh
you're right absolutely a lot I school a
lot of those things in the 80s were like
class member class where I tutor that my
tutor class lassie ends up banging his
mom on Vicky's friends mom on vacation
and they have to spend Christmas
together my right right there was
another movie called private lessons
remember that the like the maid hits on
the kids you remember that no no I
remember the title private lessons I've
it lessons that we rented a nerd she
puts on the Vader mask any banks the hot
chick champ alia
that's animal rape rape then statutory
rape isn't it yeah that's just straight
straight I like know that straight up
dark side rape yes but not even as an
assist from Cosby just know is straight
in there was a champion which was if you
bought it you were raped that's a Steve
Steve ed which is garbage let me just
say they don't talk about the Indian
friend with the Indian what I can you
take this guy on the road with you the
Indians because I sell tickets [ __ ]
ginger get a middle yeah where is the
middle is the the Indian friend on
Vision Quest members name but I dated
once an Indian girl in high school and I
will tell you she gave great scalp I
think that our guys not supposed to bits
on us well I don't think that
constitutes a bit holy crap hey it's off
my first album will say at that point my
first album is called she gives good
scalp yeah Steve tell us marine about
the TV show that you're on eight years
ago was called uh our year ago who is
cultures revisited Eddie who yeah all
right um so you did do a tour with your
show though didn't you we did tour three
Sullivan & Son yeah we did no plurals
right excuse me just Sullivan & Son
Sullivan & Son yeah ok attention johnny
was on Wikipedia two minutes before they
had to go the bathroom I the opportunity
who know that's pretty much where I got
to know Gary too cuz Gary had done the
warm up and then we were all going out
together and Gary's just such a piece of
[ __ ] Thanks sorry all right let's bring
let's bring him along warming up warming
up the crowd with that scalp bit oh yeah
oh yeah they loved it I mean it was so
crazy to be having fans come up to you
and just say hey the first 10 minutes
were the best of the show okay good mean
cuz it went me a med but you know where
this is going one of the best group of
dramatic actors that I've ever worked
with oh okay so wait you warmed up with
all the comp cuz it was all comics
pretty much on the show right it was
comics it was my snot you right you're
not you're not a part of it oh you're
behind the camera right it was on
Benjamin Roy Wood jr. a meta med myself
okay
so that's all comics yeah did you or did
every comic do a bit before the show no
real we were rehearsing our we were
memorizing aligns yeah that wasn't just
improv that without you Gary first I
thought it was like Sarah netlogo it is
a script yeah yeah and somebody wrote it
yeah ye yeah what did you happen to you
have to introduce everybody yeah yeah
yeah like that was your thing yeah he
would introduce me as just give me
shitty intros and Here I am I'm star
creator / do you know and then he psyche
that low on the last one in the curtain
call he goes ladies and gentlemen just
graduated from the Rob Schneider Academy
of Dramatic Arts Stabler said Gary
anyone's literally you know as in terms
of warm up kick the best warm-up gig
I've ever had because I literally would
you [ __ ] on the show on the cast I mean
and so this is my first ever do first
drama the TBS is filmed in front of a
live studio audience yeah and then
people would be like hey when's this
gonna air and I would never see the
light of day I mean it was just like
literally hey uh this is the The Young
and the Restless revisited it just like
it's so and as a warm-up guy like you're
never you're always kind of like on the
side of you know them you're on that
team course but but it was funny because
then the audience and they would come up
and try to say something to make fun of
me and the audience would boo them
because I had the audience on my side so
then they would be against them for just
being shitty to me meanwhile I'd been
[ __ ] on them for the last three
hours now everything you want to warm up
Steve yeah your show oh yeah it's where
has worked all these years to get my own
show and the [ __ ] warm-up guy is just
gonna [ __ ] he's literally just saying
what all the executives are thinking
yeah who is I remember there was that
time where somebody was like either
sleeping in the audience or whatever and
I said oh that's uh Robert right or
whatever president TBS so how many dates
did you guys do with the whole show uh
summer we did I think 25 cities yeah
yeah what was that three years we were
on for 33 years we were on we were
summer show so every summer we toured
and so it's kind of funny because I look
and I love these guys but everybody's
like all the undateable guys they have
this show about a barn
go to this comet or you guys should go
do into a we're like no we did it we
were on the air before them and we had a
show about a bar and my guys were in and
we did the torso but I I'm glad to see
that uh somebody's doing it successfully
cuz they're they're doing really well on
this show keeps getting picked up and uh
you look Tilly I've known him for years
at the store could be a nice guy yeah
yeah so it's also a network that helps
yeah being on network helps and then you
know we were look we were a summer show
in the middle of AD supported basic
cable television and we'd never really
you know that I mean TBS did their fair
share of trying to help get the word out
but ultimately it was kind of fell to
our laps to to to do what we could so
all those existing relationships we had
word radio stations we just went and
just said hey can we come and do the
radio and the show is almost secondary
right cuz we're trying to get the word
out sure the biggest piece of press that
Sullivan Sun God was I think steve was
quoted once in the street sheet and then
I think a med was in the trader joe's
newspaper so it's like well it's just
hard when you can't get press of inter
you know so total sister exactly exactly
Justice just let the silent dude
permeate the room where nothing no lad
outdated his scalp reference haha ya
know if that was unbelievable my
question is how do you how do you who
went on the road you Owen Ahmed and uh
Roy and Gary hey all of a sudden you've
been on the show before our know how do
you manage all those egos on the road
and there's really only two in there we
know who they are well it you know
everybody kind of got along I gotta say
you know it really was a great tour we
had a blast we look were four guys that
knew we could be you know be doing this
you know the whole year but we get to go
to the Warren a lot we get to do a show
let's enjoy every second and this
because we're we're providing a
television show were all on so we had a
blast and I'd say the first two years
especially we [ __ ] hittin re we
partied pretty really hard and then the
third year were like our let's do you
know we're a little tired let's
just you know everywhere every other day
right now when I was it was a blast you
have four strong headliners on there
what do you guys do 20 each yet when th
but I gotta tell you who are the four
[ __ ] yeah I will say this there's
Gary uh Roy Wood in my opinion of all of
us yeah was the best comic on the tour I
still think that I thought that the
first time I saw Roy I thought Roy is a
guy that never got an hour special
nobody ever gate he never got a half
hour he didn't get the Comedy Central
Presents he presented so many times she
was like Morgan Freeman and shawshank
and I just saw this guy one at the
improv this before Sullivan son I got
that dudes [ __ ] hilarious and what a
great voice he should be doing cartoons
and Pixar movies and then I wrote this
thing and I go I gotta get that guy in
because he's so goddamn funny i call
them i didn't know i'ma like Roy I'm
gonna write this thing you don't know me
we met casually but I love you to take a
look at his again okay you write a pilot
Los Angeles of course like six months
later he's there reading for it and now
he's doing the daily show and I I hope
to god it's I'm so glad America finally
gets to see the talent that I saw right
and all the other comics have seen over
the years saying why don't you because
he doesn't wear skinny jeans and a
facial hair and have on harmless plastic
glasses and you know he's not afraid
he's had two big f you to Comedy Central
because they don't want to give him a
special now he's getting more exposure
every day exactly yeah so he doesn't
give a [ __ ] and he's around for a while
and he's row so much material that when
somebody gives him that our Amy's gonna
be lights-out he's a [ __ ] killer yeah
so when you were when you were doing
Sullivan someone you were trying to
figure out the people that you're
because obviously the four guys for
Sullivan son looks like an episode of
comics unleashed right you have a black
eye en female I mean it really is just
every generic stereotype that you can
think of or my friends here comes the
cowboy and the cowboy hat here comes the
you know the Eskimo with a [ __ ] spear
all sitting around the bar well if you
robot it will just be for unemployed
comics that all do warm up hanging out
at a note
waiting for somebody else to get a show
yeah you guys can warm it up but you're
getting your internet you're racist
racism confused there i asked him of the
spear Oh animal with the harpoon there
you go there we go yeah yeah seems just
jealous cuz eyes to be to plunder the
warner brothers lot every day I'm not
jealous I can't wait to Steve as he
drives bypass Avenue hoping somebody
called him a drive on [ __ ] you go ahead
so you guys are in the road together
after this right yeah no ticket required
tour ok show up 380 friends large groups
welcome yeah at the last minute Steve
would you like to plug your Chicago
special that you can plug on our show
the last few wheels [ __ ] last few weeks
it was just announced one week ago Gary
so sleazy Steve's doing his new
recording obviously listen I mean these
last DVDs have been really killing it
obviously because yeah he's still here
doing a podcast with me but he's doing a
brand new special in Chicago bebi where
the six you can order tickets in advance
or show up at the theater the day of
look through any Trash Can and find a
bulk of 12 so it's your call if you want
to buy them in advance and to see what
best last show I marika I got the last
five minutes of it got it right yummy
where you taping it up I'll Lincoln
halls I don't mind a cobbler shop as I
put my shoulder like your uncle [ __ ]
this is why I stopped at one kid cuz I
don't want to [ __ ] referee my kids
fighting and bickering all the take it
down take it down put the whole it's
just one kid it's true yapping the whole
time another kid going I'm gonna
headline this weekend I and this way i
have material for that supports his
father this is one of those unique yeah
i remember the good old days marie when
we used to tour the road with Sullivan &
Son Steve would be like let me pick up
this check I got it I got it I got it
all of a sudden it's like hey let's just
split the appetizer i'll pick up half of
the chicken finger never happened all of
a sudden I little these little benefits
start going away I'll be like hey I'll
grab the coffee's I'll grab the dinners
and stuff like that it's like Steve
never fights me anymore just like you
know all of a sudden I'm paying for our
hotel rooms on the road both of ours you
know it's just it's the crazy thing
about the brings that brings a serious
question i'm the owner as your career
days at a hotel and steve has the condo
as that's a no my value as a career
feature yet the guy he'll never had not
incur a future emission and make more
money than I'd like your head feel
comfortable featuring he has to go to a
club being asked what announcements
would you like me to say whose birthdays
yeah can I just open was showing you
where the fire exits are probably my
first five minutes as fire exits then we
go over the stop drop and roll now do
you find that uh that headliners will
take care of you as the feature on the
road yeah McGann Steve suppose most of
them will I think that they do you know
what a worsted you are such a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] lying you are look at you
right now you can't even you can't even
look if you're not smiling looking right
here on a [ __ ] word it's like I'm
sitting it in a more vital in the rod
what am I saying words true Oh what am I
saying that's not true you've never
bought a meal I'll tell you this we
finished the tour three three summers we
tour Sullivan or sun we go to this great
dinner it's the end of the tour little
did we know it's a lot end of the tour
we're in Hawaii we go to cold stone ice
cream place my wife and Gary Gary's like
you know what I got the ice cream thank
you Gary very much I go to bed I wake up
the next morning the cold stone receipt
is slipped under my door any circles I'm
my life charges yeah and he says you oh
yeah yeah you're Steve eat whenever at
the 99-cent store seems quick to we
never been another nine minutes on the
dollar tree whenever we're one of those
stores I don't don't need to go back
where you went school shopping for
clothes Allah up again I'll pick up the
whoopee cushions today and then whenever
we're at some more decent not enough
steve has all of a sudden this wallets
lost you know mr. short hands deep
pockets over there yeah never get
anything i love i miss working with
those guys that you know sell tickets
right how did I just I notice is if I
can load a question right now the how'd
you guys meet uh I was a performer on
the late late show with craig kilborn at
the time and you were again uh audience
warm up so it's so funny because back
then i was doing just a set right and i
went on how to show and i'm doing but
you always play movie or still doing the
same [ __ ] I mean obviously those TV
spots and the show that you created I
mean they're all exploding yeah I mean
look at we're both sitting here in a
[ __ ]
dark room with this guy yeah well I
don't know your [ __ ] [ __ ] I go back
to my home with a pool but you rent a
new you have a donkey kong machine in
your line right right 700 feet yeah okay
yeah absolution we're the same why don't
you tell your little daughter what
repossession means go ahead he's been
doing this joke for three weeks Maria
doesn't nothing or nothing even errands
like he's been doing everybody knows
honestly tell me the story how we met
this it's a great store I met him he did
the laid the Late Late Show warm up and
then I just see him at the improv and
he'd always being seeing shows never
doing an actual set kohl's you know all
that same [ __ ] uh and when I got
Sullivan & Son I was like I know a guy
think that would be great for warm-up
and I called cannon and he actually had
never done a sitcom before um and I
still just kept pushing for him because
I was like you it's a huge element when
you're filming in front of lots do I
need them amped and I think so so many
shows you go to tapings it's almost like
casual they don't even think about or do
just throw Jimmy up for five minutes and
he'll do stand out it's like you know
you need somebody to amp them up because
tape and could be three hours could be
four or five hours and you need somebody
to sustain the energy in the room and
Gary Gary's good at that right well
that's it's funny I will say this cuz I
got a call from the producer of Sullivan
& Son at the time he was doing the pilot
and he said hey Steve really wants you
to do warm up on a show and the truth
was I really didn't know you all that
well I mean I'd seen you on different
peddler telethons on but this was like
the first time I'd you know actually you
know I was trying to get your cell phone
number from the guy he said she doesn't
have a cell phone um I said why she
doesn't want one and guys I can't afford
it um so we're doing anything I'm not
trying to go it's all a joke you look
dude you just deliver that joke and you
look at both of us like right no keep
going so he calls me he says hey you
want to do this show that Steve's doing
I at the time thought it was just a
Comedy Central show like a one-off you
know just whatever that was not supposed
to be New York at the time and I don't
know if you remember this the date
actually of that pilot changed it was
supposed to be like first weekend of
November thousand eleven and then it
went
the second weekend in november and so I
really I a ton of warm-up experience but
no sitcom experiencing every warm-up
will tell you the hardest gate to get is
a sitcom it really is cuz you gotta make
that leap of really filling three four
five hours depending on how long these
things take and just jumping in every
single second when they're rewriting or
doing something different um so I really
I truthfully just didn't have sitcom
experience so Kent the guy that wanted
to bring me on was very skeptical about
it and I think he kind of knew I didn't
have experience but I was just trying to
lead on that I did so Steve kept pushing
and he's like don't worry we're gonna
get you in we're gonna get you in and
basically what I did was for the pilot
when we film the pilot on this Sunday
afternoon I went out just cuz I didn't
know how I was gonna go I went out just
with my own money just bought a bunch of
gift cards because I thought even if the
audience is just subpar I'm gonna goose
them with free [ __ ] yeah so it turned
out we take two shows that day the
rehearsal at three the real show at five
and it's crazy to look back on that time
because pilots usually take a long time
to film just because everybody's new
there's no connection yet it's a little
off most pilots take four or five six
hours to film I'll never forget this we
started that show at six we were out by
nine o'clock so the audience sustained
the whole time they were great that the
gift cards really didn't even come into
play because the audience was so good
her and then the show got picked up and
we did another nine episodes did another
two seasons after that and it really as
much as I bust use balls I mean that
show let just so many other sitcoms and
other great things that as much as I
hate to give steven credit for this
lucky this great gift that I've had over
the years by doing these sitcoms and you
know I'm not working on this dr. ken
show for ABC whatcha say no Suzy
Nakamura do oh yeah she's great with her
yeah yeah a real actor which is kind of
a nice change from anyway and then um it
was great because Ken knew me from
Sullivan & Son he was on on Sullivan son
did a couple guest appearances so when
he got his show he immediately called me
today we really need you for our show
and it's just great I mean it just yeah
I've been able to bounce around and
build up this nice resume of other
sitcoms that would have been so hard to
do had I not done Sullivan
son so you're getting a light on this
story buddy how'd you meet whoa thank
you okay now you're probably fortunate
enough to get fans over the years of
doing the show right I'm not with the
same killer singular yes over the show
so you get more so you get more people
they're comin dis I did warm up dude and
I did work out for like MTV and vh1 when
nobody wanted to be there that sure
their audience and it was [ __ ] oh
yeah but if they're coming to see
Sullivan & Son they're already pretty
jazzed and it's right you don't have to
fly over Gary laughter Aaron anywhere
who I was coming in here why did not
warn me unique weeds this thing has been
set up for a week I'm talking to Aaron
the producer of us just shaking his head
over there we drove across town Aaron
you know that right I drove across town
pretty jazzed [ __ ] kill be these are
the same audience members that as their
up heading up into the audience they're
buttoning their pants these are guys
with face tattoos pretty jazzed this is
the most accurate item I'm try that no
dish maybe I'll get somewhere I'm sure I
met that same crappy audience that we're
at your MTV shows these guys were here
for the free sandwich and a snickers bar
my friend okay they weren't pretty jazz
talk to Steve yeah for a few minutes
here's the thirty dollars I think we're
heading our co to get a sandwich where'd
you get started Steve uh New York City
doing what oh really what here 97 okay i
moved to I'd i studied at Kent State I
went to New York my parents were living
there at the time i see ohio kid no
pittsburgh grew up in Pittsburgh what's
going on how my grades sucked so I had
to go out of state and huh and yeah yeah
I my second time on stage I ended up
working at carolines comedy club just
sweeping floors and not answering the
phones i never been to a stand-up club
never wanted to do stand-up and then I
worked in the club and I thought that
looks like fun so like three months
later I tried up at stand-up New York
and then the second time went to new
york comedy club like a week later and
this guy Roger Paul was in the audience
and yes but you know his booking agent
is a booking B&C rooms and he goes
here's my card call me we'll be in touch
you gotta meet with me when can we meet
I'm like oh I'll meet you tomorrow I go
over there he's like how long you been
doing I'm like those my second time he's
like are you kidding me and he put me on
the road right away no next so I i
started working kinda like what kind of
it what is Roger Paul book these days or
those days I guess uh lot of like one
nighter yeah a lot of bars east coast
and then I was going into the you know
MC like comedy zones I would Lily
rent-a-car New York City and drive down
to like oh god it like like Nashville or
something then see it did you know
whatever club they have there are zanies
and then drive all the way back the 18
hours or whatever was it was just brutal
all those early is but I just I would do
anything to get stage time that's good
the good thing about New York is where
you from I forget Michigan Michigan
that's right about New York is you just
hop a bus or a train and get out to some
yes he said he chose and kinetic area
yeah exactly and then eventually I i
spent like a year on the road and then i
went to the comedy cellar an audition
and then she passed me and then all the
clubs just felt like dominoes and I I
was in New York I for like six years
seven years just at the sellers
literally every single night of my life
Thanksgiving Christmas New Year's Eve it
didn't matter and i was doing five six
shows a night it was the best what would
how many how many does she have now and
her on her roster do you think meeting
over at the seller comics / night well
just on her roster like she keeps a very
tight yeah i mean look it's like it's
like I've never I never even tried to
get into seller because I don't spend
much time in New York anyway but uh I
don't know I mean it's gotta be there
were 40 people but you know again it's
like there's some guys that are in town
then they're out of town and she keeps
your rights yummy she does keep a tight
crew but I was always on after midnight
so is always it was literally for like
years it was Godfrey Lampanelli me Artie
fuqua hmm always closing now from like
12 right Gary you know Gary Gulman
obviously oh yeah great guy Gary says he
goes on the road just to have jokes for
comedy cellar well it's I mean the
seller is one of those places where you
know I there's no other Club like it
where do you know it is so intimate any
mornings is literally they could touch
you so you're just thrown into this
gladiator pit where you've just got to
play you gotta come through or you're
not coming back Lily she's not gonna
book you period so you gotta you gotta
bring it cuz you do want to be a part of
that I mean is a reason Seinfeld Louie
rock Chappelle Robin when he was alive
Romano all those guys come through there
every single time that they're in town
or they're warming up for Letterman
they're always there and there's a
reason for it mm-hmm where's your
favorite place to perform the seller can
jump in on this too Gary it was a 90 I
know me guess I know Warner Brothers lot
no I don't wear steve says cuz we've
talked about this what wherever there's
people i know i don't think that's a dig
I think that's a great work ethic yeah i
think that proves why he's a headliner
and has his own show of course were you
working this weekend I'm in town yeah
okay well i'll be at the hollywood
improv and like well I don't know feel
free to come by do a guess it sure
somebody where we were in a show shirt
from kohls there no no you know what I'm
not gonna fall for that trick is then I
do the gesetz he's like he can grab a
seat in the own insole look more parked
where's Mike [ __ ] no Gary Gary can't do
a set unless he comes in and goes hey
what's this [ __ ] ed area town okay good
Steve can't perform unless he gets a
call that day for his booking agent you
do that shitty joke i got a call two
sold-out shows in vegas don't do it
never happened this is your shot this is
his show I know I know at him moderating
the monetary sorry Jesus the wedding
today what guy said you look good I
showered for notice i showered for this
job i like i like what's your what's
your favorite clubs performing i love
the clubs in arizona those are great as
they often I like Chicago improv a lot
I'm pointing at you you do schomburg
yeah yeah Alex gago improv a lot I like
the schaumburg room but it just when
you're working in Chicago it's like I
wanted you 30 minute I like they all the
time I never get to see chicken so next
time I'm going I'm going in a day early
cuz I never get to see ya you want to
see the city you want to hang out to say
that's like the great thing about
all PF j yeah yeah I man how do they go
great Chinese food yeah acts like the DC
improv is one of my favorite Club
backcountry cuz it's like again compact
small low ceiling the laughs are
enormous in there but then you're four
blocks away from the White House and the
mall and you could walk around and see
all the different museums it's great
it's so fun being there cuz again these
days everything just like PF changs you
know yes summer is just you know yard
house it's like I don't want to go to
the yard house after my show I want to
find a hole in the wall bar where it's
kind of cool and you need some good food
at each chain restaurants all the time
yard house PF changs and old navy are
always well within a stone's throw of an
improv thank God for barnes and nobles
cuz if they didn't exist I didn't know
what I do in between shows right i've
diddled navy save my ass cuz I left my
clothes in the car really I'm sorry to
go on stage not looking this nice well
until i got and i'm in a ratty shorts
and a shirt and i had to call the house
is funny i had to call the tow truck guy
to unlock my door so i had to go up this
is a long time ago yeah I was opening
the show says as a long time and uh and
I'm like I locked my cut but I call it
but I called the triple a guy so the guy
came between during the middle act so he
got i unlock the door you know like i
got changed i came back up dressed and
very nicely as everybody as the middle
act was leaving and everybody cheered
for me because they saw that I had
gotten my clothes on and he thought he
was [ __ ] he just [ __ ] also fun I got
like two steps off the stage and he's
like oh thank you threw his arms up
higher but everybody's cheering for me
this holder bemin Gary cannon I why I
will say this about that was Gary this
is this a funny story every city we go
to Steve and I for their three four
nights we'll pick a night maybe to go
out and tie one on usually we'll figure
it out but as we go into the city on
maybe that Thursday Steve will say like
you know what I'm out this weekend I'm
just I'm laying low you know trying to
be good this that and the other thing we
were in Atlanta but three weeks ago and
I got there on friday and I meet Steve
and he's like we're heading to the show
and he's like I think after the shows
tonight I may just go back to the hotel
and work out get a late night workout
not only do we not get a late
work out we get Steve get shit-canned
well [ __ ] to the point where you know
yeah I walk into this bar this guy
recognizes me he's the bartender and
he's running the joint next and on
behind the bar pouring shots now charges
everybody's doing shots shots just keep
coming and I'm like I'm starting to get
[ __ ] up here and then all the sudden
something just I I disappear it's not me
anymore I'm not I don't remember the
back half of the night and you do what
we literally went in we were working the
Atlanta improv and we leave and we're
trying to find a bar just to go have a
drink at a quiet little bar and every
bar is all college kids 21 22 we go to
this one bar you can't even get through
it we look like the two creepy dads
there to pick up our son well 11 does so
we finally find this bar it's getting
late in the night it's probably like one
o'clock the bars close at like jus 215
this guy the bartender recognizes you
and so he's we're drinking a four yeah I
mean why we end up drinking till three
thirty four o'clock I mean they stay
open we're secretly drinking is there
sweeping up and then we go to this food
truck right out front of the bar and
Steve literally knocked my glasses off
of my head and they fly into the food
truck he doesn't remember this you
knocked my glasses off why did he know
you probably deserve so we each get a
burger and a hot dog to take home Steve
leaves his in the in the truck I bring
my backup I'm pretty I'm not even that
draw I'm but you know like every abuse
housewife at some point shoots their
husband rakia stop beating me right
that's what happened I was a burning
this is your burning bed moment I'm
thinking if I didn't deserve it then it
was probably from something that
happened over the last month so I'm like
get mad so then I go to sleep I friends
in Atlanta I go see them the next day on
Saturday everything's great I don't hear
from steve at all saturday cuz he's like
let's go see a movie let's go ba ba ba
ba ba and nothing so then what happens I
see you that night at the show you look
like a zombie i mean i right i woke up
at like later in the day I was like
there's no way I can even do the show I
feel so awful i thought i was gonna have
to cancel saturday i felt so sick and
then I get there and I tell Gary I'm
like I was so
[ __ ] up last night this is never
having me in all the years I've done
stand-up i woke up at six thirty in the
morning I wake up I holy [ __ ] and I'm
bombed and I'm feeling awful and my
breath stinks but I'm just like it's 630
I get all my [ __ ] and throw it in the
suitcase I run downstairs I jump in a
cab ago you got to get me the airport
now my flights at seven fifteen he's
driving to the airport ah i look at my
phone Mike it's 630 I can't make a say
it's 45 minutes pay I'm not gonna make
the flight there's no [ __ ] way why am
I even going and then I look and I'm
like it's Saturday I'm so [ __ ] up I
thought it was sunday and I just was
going to the air I've never been that
bombed in my life it but I'd asked you
this before when you're driving back
from the airport are you relieved like I
go back to sleep and thank God I can
just go and pass out yeah but the good
news was you didn't check out of the
room or anything dick could you imagine
if you know I never check out I was just
tell you right yeah who'd your club mean
for us a fun right you don't have to
check out anyway just leave the key
that's true yeah but I mean you were
just so hammered and how great was that
feeling going back into the room just
joking out yeah must be the greatest but
then throwing up the whole day just
awful I've forgotten so drunk that I've
almost had to cancel from a hangover
I've done a hungover that's the worst
yeah when I did it over the next night
yeah that that was the case that day I
mean I was dragging the first show and
you even said the first 10 minutes oh
just yeah all you told the crowd to you
said you know war Nomos okay and then 10
minutes in you know I'm on autopilot and
it just get the gears kick in you're
like okay here we go there's no show
you've done these jokes a million times
we can do it you they do our [ __ ]
you have a daughter a daughter three and
a half i got a boy do literally any
moment now really have my phone by me
because my wife is today is the is the
do data oh geez actual due date yell
congratulations thank you very have it
by the next time i see you as that
slowed you down on the road at all
having kids no it's kind of like the
hurt locker where you know there's a guy
that goes to war comes back home in the
family and then like like two weeks in a
hangar with the families like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i'm going back to home I have to go
back or I beat you yeah I think I don't
remember her
locker at something about spousal abuse
I think no no he never hit all right he
was just like no he was just like it's
like every guy that that's like I'm
gonna retire from the game I'm spending
time with my family and like three
months later psych I'm back baby I'm
signing with the team [ __ ] the fail but
I love my family I love it I love
spending time with them they come on the
road with me sometimes but for the most
part it's I'm so driven towards towards
the mentality of having a body of work
and not just one special I I my goal was
always to have six or seven by the time
I was all done so there's a slow you
down drinking though in the room I i
I've definitely done a lot less as I've
gotten older I'm sure you have as well
where you know with kids you just don't
just call me old the like a dead it was
called me love 41 how old do you know 43
yeah I mean you know for tom bling 40
1242 I'm not 52 no we were when we were
younger we owe ya drank you yard Charlie
goodnight you like is why is the [ __ ]
best then you heal up like Wolverine
you're ready to drink the next day like
noon but nowadays it's like [ __ ] I just
I just remember I don't remember what
city we were any was either like
Charlotte or maybe one of the night she
was in cleveland or something like that
where we tied one on like every single
night baby was in Cleveland Cleveland at
Crawford tie one on every night and
finally it's like Saturday were like
enough of this [ __ ] already and then all
it just starts off with just one just
why it's always it's was just that one
and then for yet there was that one i
think it was in charlotte maybe where we
went we got back to the hotel that smoke
alarms going off we got to get my god
cuz it's like you know we have a flight
in two hours and it's just like to over
this [ __ ] yeah that's going off in the
middle of the night oh yeah the whole we
got back to the hotel like three in the
morning by our hotel evacuated Oh buddy
was out yet it just like we're bombed
you just want to get three hours of
sleep yeah and you know then you're like
oh we're [ __ ] it's like the the alarms
cry like fur last time I was in Vegas I
forgot about this is with Michael Paulo
sac and the alarm went off during my set
but it would go on right
I and they would stop for an
undetermined amount maybe 30 seconds
yeah be four minutes maybe of seven
minute and then you can you not and you
know it's Vegas improv so everything is
so right opener does five middle dust
out of a club well yeah you have to stay
at your time and he's letting like I'm
on there for like 25 and just he's like
I'm like I'm supposed to get out of here
like now keep going I'm telling him I'm
supposed two guys I keep going keep
going because they had to [ __ ] eat it
for the headliner so I wouldn't have the
problems with the really see the
headliner dub doing like I don't know 15
minutes I'm doing like 35 duh so the
other day I was at my
ah
and then my wife said my
and I'm just I'm just gonna wait until
it goes off again well I tell you
whenever something what distraction
always happens like that like the the
alarm will go off or sue somebody knocks
over glass it's always like you're on
stage knock knock who's there Jimmy
Jimmy who Jimmy and what the [ __ ] out
like my pet peeve is when you're in the
middle of doing a joke and then the
waitress comes up and gives you a shot
from someone in the audience right right
just before the punt day they never do
it at the setup they never do it when
you're in transition they just always
know to bring it I've never had a
waitress bring it is like perfect timing
thank you it's never they don't know
they don't wait they just always do it
then it Oh charge me wait when you got
hammered that friday night in Atlanta
the next day your friends were there and
they were sending you shots to win do it
yeah and I'm literally in the back and I
don't know if Steve could see me I saw I
say that you use egging the whole
audience and imagining and he knows I'm
sick let's see yeah yeah the good news
about that extra time that you did in
vegas i'm sure that they took care of
you and covered you for doing more Tokyo
yeah thanks em they're all about
cultivating me at worst they made it
worth my while they really took care you
at the UH at the employee karna Sarah
kiama Sarah employee commissary you
gotta work for me so all i did i did a
local club i did a deal um I don't think
if I probably told this story but this
happen last year probably told us before
I did an alcohol deal where I got a
percentage of the alcohol sold oh nice
um it was great in their workout you
huge birthday parties oh that's great
ray except like one was like an a a
birthday party so I cry but I checked in
with the well the opener was on really
checked in like so answer like they're
not really drinking they're not really
drinking so I pulled a Dean Martin and
so I'm like ring it on stage with it
like I'm gonna order shots on stage yeah
and first one bring me absolute I'm fine
with that but after that water water
shut but what if somebody wants to buy
you drink water oh yeah just water and
so that's what I did drank the first one
like happy bird let's get this thing
going as a group shots around shots
around those bang and water all night
and worked out well you know the bird
cries
sure did then for years he didn't drink
well II up makin trax bad like that that
was the the Rio a huge reason why clubs
would book him is because Lucky's a
great storytellers energetic but they
did want him in there because he got the
party going yeah and he would start
drinking he'd buy people shots he do
shots and then all the sudden the bar
tabs were just going through the roof
they like you gotta get bird in there he
slowed it down a little bit but even now
he's still oh yeah he's there for the
alcohol so yeah birds great i love bird
i remember i was doing a new years eve
show at some club and they said hey when
you go up on stage before midnight at
like 1145 make sure that you tell them
if they want to do the champagne toast
it's 55 dollars for the globe lighting
so make sure that you and i literally go
up on stage and mention this and people
are [ __ ] booing yeah like you can't
include a shitty glass of champagne with
this and I mean it was kinda it was
bizarre you mean is bizarre I've never
seen him charged extra is charged up
front you know so they don't worry no we
work in rooms Oh clubs natural club
sorry yeah this is the DC improv you
just the TC although maybe I'm in
theater so they're not used to Rio the
sales of that yeah mm alright so what
time you gotta get here um I got tagged
I thought we had at a time um like 15 20
we have 15 so i gotta move my car too
soon no we're not ending right now
although it's really cool in here yeah I
am sweating like nobody's biz well it's
like a hundred degrees outside it's we
have at our school in here very nice in
here yeah it's very nice I've got like
major back sweat going Murr Murray
sweating like Steve at the end of the
week hoping he gets a bonus [ __ ] a
right ooh yes I gettogether about that's
about time that's price carry you gotta
go move my car if only does Oh alarm was
going off I get started in Michigan or
you know Michigan don't know I didn't
get started Michigan hi Michigan ah
little john heffron from Michigan John
come on who Tim Allen Tim Allen Tim
Allen Africa
reference awesome you know john heffron
used to do he took over for uh a morning
radio show that in a huge following when
i was there as a kid he took over for a
dick burton and he was on 95 5 and then
he moved out to LA but yeah i mean i
don't think there's a lot of guys Rob
littles from Michigan few other people
I'm Michael Kosta Oh racism register
yeah he's really funny it's so fun so
funny that you'll you'll love this story
I was doing warm up for Michael he has a
show called the comment section that he
did a six-episode run of and when my
older son runs a kb anderson right wait
a piece for michigan is a is a Minnesota
so when but before Michael moved out
here I'd met Michael before at a club in
Michigan and michael is coming out to
move to LA and he brought me he said he
would love to get coffee with you to
pick your brain about you know what the
deal is out michigan so we got together
years and years ago so when I finally
did warm up on Michael show Michael
comes out and tells the story of how we
met he's like I just want to let you
guys know before I moved to LA Gary SAT
me down and told me how to you know
really get involved here in Los Angeles
in blah blah blah blah blah and like so
here I am now thanks to Gary and I was
like and I'm doing warm up I like I I
probably shouldn't have given him that
advice cuz now he's doing better than me
physician heal thyself yes right so but
michael is a funny guy yeah he is sorry
just gonna text sure Carmen Lynch no
Carmen choose New York yeah yeah okay
judo Liz melee why do I know that name
she from New York Gino liz is melee I
had her on the show I think you did
maybe I just know she's a big New York
Comic always does a lot of shows oh wait
she's with like Maria Shehata right
obviously i think i was like her and
carmen and all three hang out maybe
that's why I like Rachel's part of that
group Rachel Feinstein yeah yeah yeah
yeah Gary knows everybody I know a lot
of people from Conan people come in now
he's always asking to open forum on with
you I mean it's please do have any dates
I remember I remember I did a cruise
ones with Ralphie May it was a for the
comet cruisers uh um cão head is a radio
personality out Tampa Rouge once a year
we just died didn't he no no thing I was
like Ralph your couch yeah
well I'll second horse had a DJ at
Austin sorry okay the corset so did you
Ralphie got really sick on the cruise
really second you know they brought him
down to the infirmary and not the cruise
ship and he's really bad and this wasn't
like November day I remember just like
dare i say shetty was it something he
ate I'm not sure or was he seasick he
was at the seasick so I said to him he's
like literally not feeling good nice and
hey would this be a bad time to go over
dates for next year the worst but yeah
we I mean literally or do you ever do a
juggalo conference with him you know
he's big with the Juggalos no climbed on
insane clown posse not the insane clown
posse really know okay he's like these
big e does the juggalo conventions
Ralphie yeah yeah I did not have in Lana
really yeah you gotta go down that gig
next year i guess so i will say this
stephen i do bust balls but we do have a
great time on the road it really is a
fun dynamic I mean I know when I go on a
gig with Steve that I'm gonna lose money
but I'm like [ __ ] it you know me it's
just the experience she hates you holy
gig I know that I come back with less
money and I will say this about Steve
you're here you're only guy I you
already know this man the only guy that
brings his merge two shows in a laundry
room garment bag from the hotel
literally I mean you know gabriel
iglesias isn't doing that he's got a
[ __ ] laundry bag and the only guy I
know that goes to a show and leaves with
more merch than he started with people
will find him they will drive from a
city to return his [ __ ] merch so if
he brings 10 cds he's leaving with 15
okay nobody wants that junk chicago
februari the 60 starbucks on north and
wells stops run off that is where he's
filming it oh good time all right well
but before we get out of here no oh I
know been so lucky guy yeah it's been so
why did Mike Finn send me something for
in dropbox you know what okay all right
thanks you can't send it yeah we ever
recorded it all right good to know Tech
Talk
sorry I guess we're back so talk to us
about myspace your the wall you're you
really took off on myspace if I did my
research right ah well I i won this
myspace stand up sit down competition
that they hosted George Lopez hosted it
and you know like back in the day I was
I was just starting to do the clubs and
I'm i remember my manager like you keep
advancing in this thing and they're
gonna have this big show in Vegas and
you could win like 50 grand and you know
you should start promoting this on your
page I'm like [ __ ] that [ __ ] contests
I'm in dallas I'm headland that week and
that's where I'm going cuz I'm a comic
he's like now you should really kick and
I listened to him and then I won the
thing and people vote on and uh and I
was like awww I got it I got this at
home because because then I got a tour I
got my own tour oh cool myspace did for
a summer so I got to go to like you know
15 different cities now that was the
start of me being introduced to the
clubs where I was starting to headline
after that but it was a great experience
in them I took that money just basically
bought a loft downtown Los Angeles back
when nobody was downtown was happening
so I kind of got in at the right time as
well so was a lot of pluses but so funny
to think that myspace was such a huge
huge part of our lives back in the day
because it was the first before Twitter
Instagram Facebook this was it and
everybody was on it and I remember going
out to cities or like finding girls
targeting Phoenix and I just look at how
fine hot girls right hey I'm in town you
would come to a comedy show it was the
greatest and then it's such a joke now
right it's a graveyard for I mean people
go back to people's old profiles and
find embarrassing things and put them up
like Tom Hardy's going through that now
right but I mean back in the day myspace
was the [ __ ] I mean you guys Ron right
yeah yeah remember like that's how me
the end of the week a couple times but
the tone at the top 8th fret Thank You
40 Fox we're like a critical you mean
really I'm not in your topic about the
top it yeah then you'd have to expand it
out to the top 12 or the top 16 so you
weren't pizzicato five is when a yeah
yeah like people were mad like how are
you not putting me in your top 12 I'm in
your top 12 and you're not putting me ma
it's like I'm sorry I wanted to put John
John Lennon Paul McCartney
me and you you everybody had profiles is
like I'm gonna put the beatles in my top
80 silence I clues no room for me no not
at all her four Beatles dude you're five
what so one is what his facebook gonna
be the joke like something's gotta come
back again I don't know right is I think
if you ask like high school kids like
they don't use it they're all about
Instagram and they use snapchat I mean
it's you know Twitter's a big thing like
I think a lot of people aren't using it
as much as they once did I think it's
slowly kind of in the down slope even I
what I I was so on myspace and then
Facebook came out and I was so on
facebook and even now I'm not on
Facebook is I'm just on Twitter it's
just like it's so quick and you just see
the instant reaction of everything
that's what I appreciate you know even
like I watch a penguins game and I live
tweet with other fans watching the
Penguins and it's at all it's it's it's
a more fun dynamic as opposed to
facebook which Louie just a post then
you read the comments yeah that's kind
of it I was doing periscope for a little
while I never got on to it I hired a
periscope from daily podcast first of
all that was fun but you know it's like
no it's one of those things I wonder if
it would catch I mean like certain
things tried to catch on never did you
mean I just wonder if that that that
will to a periscope was always it was
too invasive were just like any time
yeah I just didn't like you know I just
think you devalue you a it's like let
them come see what the club yeah that's
when they get to see don't ever use me
brush my teeth it's like there's some
guys and I think we know who they are
all right there just on it non-stop and
then it it's like I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm not excited to go see that
particular person I club that night but
it's almost it's almost like when you're
talking with somebody on the phone and
they want to facetime I'm almost like
I'd rather just talk to you I like I
don't need to see your face or your
boats funny because when you call me
it's like just text me I want to talk to
you I don't understand why there's not
more Wang's on periscope or genitalia in
general Oh like I don't know like that's
what I figure pretty soon some weirdos
gonna be showing off his junk I'm sure
it's happened I don't know yeah I mean
chatroulette that's what happened
remember chato chevrolet chatroulette is
something where it was again
everything starts off innocent right and
then one guy with a hard-on will ruin it
for everybody pretty much like the
internet Gary but but chatroulette is
basically go on and you could talk to
anybody in the world and it's roulette
you just don't know where it's gonna end
up and then they slowly people would
click on somebody else and then they're
just be a dick there and he's just
jerking off and that was the demise of
chatroulette and myspace I think myspace
ended with Tom's dick pic yeah alright
guys thanks for piggybacking you know we
did we uh these guys have a show which
you can tell us about so I came into the
UH came in the studio after and yeah
only two years our house we I is an
amazing house by the way let your house
thank you very much love it repentigny
living will i live in pasadena dave i
just called you your brother's name I ya
know that that's 92 have done my brother
sing but i live in pasadena and uh yeah
i've been working with gary that we've
only done maybe 14 or 15 episodes of the
gentleman's dojo and basically the
premises we've known each other and as
you've heard throughout the course I'm
just exhausted I didn't feel like
jabbing back but y'all right I I'm
accomplished I've done things he's done
nothing and shits on me constantly
nobody so accomplished one this myspace
competition three stand-up specials and
you're still sitting here next to me and
you're going home and I'm heading to the
Warner Brothers lot [ __ ] you go ahead
Murray I don't know why that quickly
yeah I don't know why the [ __ ] you I was
like our I had two older brothers and we
stood beat the SH of each other every
day yeah beat the SH out of me yeah
actually my oldest brother's to be the
showed me my middle brother would watch
so I felt like the middle brother today
oh really yeah you were ultimately us
fighting and I just SAT back cuz a
little child nobody cares about me so
funny that are hermaphroditic uh brother
sister could get his ass kicked by the
older brother is innocent even a
hermaphrodite I know I know yeah yeah
we'll edit that out that would be very
yeah alright where can we find you guys
uh where are we we have a whole tour
schedule coming out between our the end
of the everything I have is that Steve
Byrne live okay
don't forget about that he's marked up
and everything gary has is that steve
byrne life absolutely i see note i carry
on craigslist yeah miss connection sir
with a dick pic with absolutely thanks
for listening guys thank you life on the
road it's taco dangling or strippers
waving guns and these flights canceled
flights running with the runs don't like
this bounced checks great a bachelorette
comes in the front making out for your
sides and headlights doing go more
missing merchant tried the rental car
has another megachurch turn juice keys
vagina fisted cell phone is gone one big
law and order